- [exhales]
So...
[clears throat]
Welcome back
to another installment
of "Van and Mike:
The Ascension."
Um...
You know.
[chuckles]
We're doing our best
to bring you
all the behind-the-scenes
situations that a person
would experience
when they're at the top level
of Hollywood stardoms.
And there are--
I mean, am I wrong, Mike?
There's some roadblocks
in the way.
- Well, it's like,
when you start
throwing out gold,
people get jealous.
I know we only been working
at "Key & Peele"
on set
for a couple weeks now.
I don't think
we need them anymore.
- Oh, you know what?
I'm glad you voiced it,
'cause that thought has occurred
to me many a time.
At any rate,
watch this clip.
Oh, look at
this dude's makeup.
- Oh, hey,
what's up, Vandaveon.
- What's going on, dude?
We've been driving this van
all over the place today, dawg.
I've been running a gypsy cab
up out this motherfucker.
[laughs]
Titty club, here we come.
No, I'm kidding,
I'm gonna take you to the set.
- What are you shooting, man?
- Oh, this is
for prosperity, dude.
This is for prosperity.
- Keep your eyes
on the road, man.
- Oh, sorry about that, dawg.
Hold up, man.
Look to the left for me,
see if that car coming.
see if that car.
- Are you kidding me?
- There we go, there we go.
- Are we almost there?
- I just been driving
in circles.
- Zach, tell base camp
we're coming back.
- Yeah, I'll call them
right now.
- Tell them, no, he can't
drive the van anymore.
- Zach, tell base camp
I don't know
where the location is.
- Don't fucking listen to him.
- You don't know--okay.
- No, I don't know.
I thought you had the Waze,
Google Maps or something.
- This is so fucking ridiculous.
- Okay, let me just pitch
one thing.
I got the best scene
you ain't never heard of.
- Ah, a fucking pitch.
- There's a dude who's trying
to hold his breath
and not sneeze,
but then what happen by accident
when he's trying to not sneeze,
he's also holding
his butt cheeks together,
and then like "hub-uh-uh"
sound go through his body,
and this nigga fart
out his dick.
- That--
- But I ain't even got
to the good part.
There's a girl in there,
and she's coming at him
on her knees,
like, about to suck his dick.
And the fart come out his dick
into her mouth.
And then she's like,
"I've never experienced
a dick fart before.
You a unique man."
In and out, that's the scene.
What do you think?
- It's not that bad, actually.
- All right, so,
as you can see in that clip,
I was spending a good deal
of time in that vehicle,
and Peele just talking
the whole time
about how we need to get to set,
we need to get to set,
we need to get to set.
I'm up here trying
to share ideas with him
and bounce new ideas
off of him.
- You broke his mind.
- Do you think so?
You like that idea,
right?
- He was like,
blip, "Oh, snap.
These kids is genius."
And he probably thought
I was a genius too,
to be associated with you.
- So, he's like double--
he double intimidated.
- You good.
You got your little
cute shit that you do.
We trying to come up here.
- Talking about pigtails.
- Pee-pee Longstocking.
- What? Who?
Pee-pee Longstockings.
- Go tit-for-tat
with me any day.
- Oh, my God.
He said tit-for-tat
and Pee-pee Longstocking.
Oh, this is me just
riding the wave now.
So here we gonna show you
another sketch,
a little inside stuff
back behind the scenes
and whatnot.
Take a look.
- Action.
- Introducing...
Dr. Balance.
He's an aging robotic scientist.
- Sir, we're trying
to shoot here.
Can you please move?
John, can you please move?
We're trying to shoot here.
- It's the Gray Chaser.
- John, that's your name?
He's not--
- Doesn't understand
a word you're saying.
Excuse me, sir, sir, sir, sir.
There you go.
- Totally dickless.
- No dicks.
They got as close
as they could
when they got
to that Gray Chaser thing,
and then Stan Lee kind of
pointing to her leg
by her vagina.
- Right.
- But other than that...
Pshh.
It's a barren wasteland.
- The vibe on the set
has got weird.
has got a real tension feel.
That's real weird.
I'm not sure how much longer
we can stand for this.
So we will see you next time
on "Van and Mike:
The Ascension."
- Peace.
- Well, once you hear my idea,
there's gonna be fanfare,
and you're gonna make me
executive producer.
Everything's gonna
fall into place.
I just want you to think back
to when you were young
and you were just--
you were just
a kid on the streets
with a dream...
- We got to go.
- And a joke about a dick.
- What are you supposed to be
doing right now, Mike?
What are you supposed to be
doing right now?
Yeah, exactly.
Okay, so I'm just saying...
- That's a good question,
though, that's a good question.